box box voyboy i make it a hard read
it's going to game 3
it's going to game 3 mm-hmm and who's
taking in game 3 cuz box box was
dominant in game three against force the
favorites have come out on top every
Game three Game three you can no longer
hide behind you no blunders from the
other team it your skill gap I think
increases the less time you have to play
is that a smart thing to say the skill
gap increases the less time you have to
play I would say yes to an extent but
there's also much more variance because
people are blundering more often I see
yeah III do see the variance I just
can't see voyboy doing I can't see him
like missing stuff I don't know man I
haven't seen him play that much because
honestly if I want to go to bed and
throw on some League of Legends that's
about it I'm out in two minutes but I've
seen him play chess a bit and he seems
he seems like so just so tight is that a
word you guys using chess like he's
knocking up up for you sooo fair to find
the win and I don't know if box box has
had to find the win that many times I
mean he did against forsen but I was
only after a blunder he's not really
found a win without it being handed to
him and I don't know voyboy will do that
for him I think he might sneak a game I
could not imagine he wins the whole
thing without some miracle plays turn
over to the appointment the league how
could you sleep because how many people
in this German are League players too
many too many has I will say let's get
our just shatters in there okay we work
hard Hess I have to pull up a video and
then you have to watch it okay not a
just shatter not done then you have to
react with faces that will make chat
make similar faces you have to do this
constantly it's hard work alright League
of Legends challenger sure reacting to
unusual memes number 87 that's talent
there okay I support that because it
really is a lot of work to make people
think you're being authentic when
you're well it's targeting weeds no we
all have our Styles you like to play
different openings I like to laugh
occasionally when Plumbing's all funny
well at least you listen to me when you
want to talk about opening so yeah
you've learned mm-hmm and I think if we
play it out I have a question for you if
we played well are they into it right
now yeah they just started
oh no they're into I'll ask you later I
asked you to remind me what is this
opening from box box you know it it's
the caro-kann defense it's called and
the point is you put your upon c6 to
defend your pawn d5 so if white were to
take you would take back with the pawn
and control the Senate and we can
actually listen into box box because I
think he's prepared specifically for
this match it's all coming together yes
this lesson with levy is paying off
bishop comes out boom boom oh my god
this is the first time at amount of prep
has done something
I feel like this is also in the prep am
i trading it off or am I just trading it
off what's the right answer here he
should take it because he just want to
ruin his pawn structure yeah I do
remember I do remember I'm trading it
off I know the Queen's out pretty early
and that's okay for white to have the
Queen out because it's a very closed
position won't be attacked but box box
is a pretty ideal formation with his
pawns okay after this the prep ends and
then we just play a solid as we can good
to know that he that he understands that
what you have to remember is over now
you just play chess right so he's
cognizant of where the opening theory
goes and he's like I kind of think this
is familiar but my preparation is done
with analysis cuz it's a very important
step to take and I think that's what's
helped him improve as a chess player now
we looked at Kessel the caro-kann is
very closed off so there's a lot of room
for mistakes if the plate is clean and
is the caro-kann the one he plays
because you're able to play it
consistently regardless of the other
opening is that his that's why it likes
it so the car con is in response to e4
and it plays it because it allows you to
fight for the center pretty well and as
you see here needs a now he needs bring
his night out because otherwise he loses
bishop and what's funny about this is I
had a lesson with food sleep where we
talked about this exact position it was
off stream lesson but we talked about
this exact idea yeah there's literally
only one response here right this isn't
what I remember prepping for
he's gonna find it
Oh No the line I prepped Pro is
different from this I think I should
have thought about that move more
he's highlighted both but he only is
looking at the top one so I think it was
more just a cursory thing for chat that
he's highlighting d7 I think he says
we're his own oh yeah that's a blunder
oh no he didn't bring it to d7 and I
think it's a scenario where like you
highlight it you understand that the
knight can move there but you don't
seriously consider it
because you know that generally c6 is
where a good knight goes right and
that's a problem is when you rely too
much on your memory and you're like oh
you're saying oh my Knights was to go
there but this is not the right position
and you continue doing what you've been
told but unfortunately it's the wrong
time yeah that's we just go back here
after the check he was gone Knight to d7
and protect his Bishop yeah I would not
feel good about my position now going
against the favorite and also being down
a piece and what how many moves this is
eight moves yeah so it doesn't look good
for game 1 but I don't know how do you
play when you're down this early what do
you do now so actually hit car in our
time with us earlier because Hikaru was
playing mashings magnus carlsen the
world champion and he was winning by one
game and then he lost a game but he lost
it so badly that you he just like I
played one of the worst games I'll play
and you forget about it so you don't
kind of eat yourself up the way you
would if you're outplayed by your car
okay so you just speed run through the
game or you just like you know you try
but you know you don't exert all your
mental force into a game that you just
kind of had a dumb mistake on early yeah
I always believed you should keep
playing especially in a time which were
like this and it's not like boy boy he's
a great player but he's not finding
every single last perfect move to ice
the game so there's still a possibility
for mistake but yeah I think you
ultimately have to go in all right
I'm in a tough spot let me try to make
the most of my chances but let's really
get mentally ready for the next game and
conserve that kind of mental energy and
well we have voyboy
here we'll tear his thoughts because I'm
sure he's not thrilled to win in this
manner it doesn't feel great when you
kind of are the recipient of a blunder
mm-hmm I go Bishop here though if pawn
pushed on his castles ruined and I could
offer the trade here and I developed my
piece of nkb castles then I could take
stakes that's not bad I think takes away
some of these defensive pieces too
let's try that
oh I thought I could change the diamond
boggles got an angry face I want
something happy
why doesn't just pop up a settings thing
he does seem focused on name at hand
Hess yep I don't want to forfeit the
match by changing my flair but I really
wanted to see what I read want to make
it like a smiley face or something
I don't also see it though if I do it
he's probably not worth tell us great
now sanely analytical idea I do like
this move from box box though yeah he's
opening a potential attack on the Queen
it's the same thing I was thinking of if
he now takes cuz he was talking about
taking with Bishop if you take with your
knight then you get a little bit of
tempos black yep that's it
you tagged the Queen and behind the
Queen that pawn okay so here just go
Queen back P castles so K could also go
here takes if Queen takes I'm just trade
and I'm winning if Knight takes if
Knight takes then like you seeing the
idea of it I go here check Rick would
have to block and then I could take here
if Rick takes here what best things
about boy boy is he really is thinking
about every possibility yeah and
obviously there's no way he can see
every single last move in the response
to every move but he does a really good
job of just like saying what are the
possibilities here what do I have to
avoid and he eventually came the
decision to take this the tickets night
with his bishop what's interesting is I
feel like everything he's thinking about
is an offensive move mm-hmm I don't
think I've heard him even say once maybe
I should consider castling I think he
understands that like it's his pressure
to play cuz he has every piece moved up
and he can go for you know some eventual
mate or just attack on the black side
yeah he is up a piece but you're raising
a kind of a good point here that when
you're up a piece you may get complacent
we have material I don't need to do
anything but then you have its back and
it can be problematic he's saying I'm
gonna keep up the pressure stead oh I
don't even let box box back into the
game yeah and this is literally he
talked us through what he's now walking
us through which is crazy yeah he said
every single thing that's gonna happen
and what he'll do to respond to it and
so he's taken what I think five seconds
off the clock to make all those moves
that box box is taking about three
minutes to do yeah I think that really
shows voyboy his experience because he
played chess as a child and he played in
some competitive tournaments so really
well you know with that kind of
background I think he feels more
confident whereas Albert's rating is
1,300 you see box box 13 11 he has
gotten quite good but he's not always
confident in his choices he's like
second-guessing himself whereas voyboy
at now they're moments where it maybe
he's a little too confident which oh I'm
gonna go for this idea and then oh shoot
I should have seen that my opponent has
this response yeah so I think that's
where experience really pays off yeah I
mean he took a minute to make that move
I think voyboy already decided his
response would be to take on b7 you
might be considering other things now
because you can see the board but when
it's true it's a good one confidence is
what I like the most I think you lack
confidence in chess dare I say yes
Robert I think I think all the newer
players who just started competing we
lack confidence and what our move
supposed to be and what's right or wrong
I think that's true I think it's very
true and it's easy to get down on
yourself like you miss a movie like oh
how could I miss that and part of its
that all the information is in front you
even if you're not nobody is going to
find all the right moves but you're it
is there there's nothing hidden right
there's no way huh pawn in your back
pocket that you could throw onto the
board so I think that's part of what
frustrates people but I also think that
I mean I'm saying this to you as well
even though work but equals as
commentators but I think that as a newer
player that it's very important not to
just like get too down on yourself and
think how could I make that mistake and
I think actually
Spock's in particular is great at
analyzing his games even when he loses
and he's still in high spirits because
he is enjoying the learning process
without being too down on himself when
he blunders yeah that makes sense
yeah I think at our levels that's kind
of like a similar we get that for sure
right and okay now he took on b7 because
this nighttime d4 is hitting this is
work on c6 so let me ask you how would
you try to salvage this game if you were
box box oh yeah great if I'm box box in
the scenario I'm thinking this Queens
not in the best spot
let's get her let's yeah let's keep her
in this position and limit the places
she can go and I think box box sees that
idea so literally blocked the Queen to
being able to do one move that's right
and then from there you can get some
sort of continued pressure on her and
let's tune into box box to hear his
thoughts because now he actually has a
pretty decent chance to trap that Queen
can he escape
I don't think he can escape oh my god I
think I got his Queen
the most ASMR sign ever heard in my life
I think that's a problem
I think that happens on both sides the B
file is so tempting that's assuming goes
here in case for you
oh no he then goes here he really wants
to trap that queen here's the right idea
yeah I don't think you can get it and
that's not my intelligence talking
that's just me looking at this chart I
think I didn't fully get his Queen which
which does not happen like guaranteed
getting a queen or else I'm assuming the
black will be much more favorable right
right if that Queen were to be trapped
in the a better sport would be heavily
in Black's favor whereas now it's about
level feels like their muscle is working
now the thing is that he has to realize
Ludwig Hermes the queen is trapped and
stuck there so even the Queen goes to
aid it's not getting out in the near
future so he can castle and bring his
FEMA safety to help bring the rook into
the game to then go and try to trap the
Queen yeah there's still an advantage
even if you don't get everything right I
don't think there is one
but the good news for him is that night
seat and tasseling are the two main
moves for black here and both of them
are good moves okay not sure if you're
on a call with him but he immediately
goes for a castle nope only person I'm
gonna call with is really no way to
finish this off water that goes here if
only I could go here but I can't drive
that night off there's gotta be a way to
finish off this Queen he was here a long
time yeah hopefully you realizes the
time aspect and that he but then if my
knight moves he can just trade one for
all the resources into figuring out if
there even is a tactic there's still way
to finish it off but he clearly has the
right idea he's he's ready to pounce on
that Queen you just need to put it all
together
wait actually maybe there is
he has sprayed the night back there he
does it he's looking at it
there it is I'm not sure about the
timing on this I have to act quick okay
cool
it looks like he's abandoned trying to
get this Queen and decided to make an
attack of his own the thing is so
because he wants to trap the Queen
immediately he might not see the move
Queen to c7 which then frees the night
up to move and I can show this now on
the board that you've got Queen c7 and
black gets one free move I'm going to
move my knight away from c8 to a7 and
then your queen is totally trapped over
here in a oh so there is a trap yes oh
come on don't quit Holly quit already
damn the hessian trap who would have
known well I think it's still fine right
I mean he's he still has the Queen
locked in there
I guess yeah he has an attack on the
night which was his goal right and you
think I'd given his King a check here as
well I think the problem is can he stop
that pawn which one the pawn on a for
right now can it not just pressure the
rook and then throw this all to shambles
it can and if I was probably a useful
move but I also think it's a hard one to
Nasseri play when you think that your
Knights under attack and you're tinks on
the center but a five is actually a very
good move bloodwood gambit
it is the a five bonus you're really
good with pawns on that flank over there
it's only the only fire I look at for
the other part the other pawns don't
matter B through ages are jokes and he
does play it the Ludwig gambit coming in
two games straight so you're on a call
with voyboy
oh come on I just look the Ludwig app
needs to spread awareness and we do it
took a lot of a gambit it's called a
marketing tactic oh wait do you see that
okay that was a huge decision he decided
to give away both rooks in favor of
taking the Queen and the night yes like
a positive trade okay that was crazy
because here the Queen could have
escaped back through a seven yeah
because the Queen is no longer over on
the Queen side so he could have escaped
with his Queen instead he decided to
sacrifice the Queen for two rows and
losing the night but this pawn is very
strong he does avoid boys relying on
this very strong pawn on d6 yeah that
was uh that was bold I think I think it
was worth it I think he's putting all of
his efforts and thoughts into like this
Queen and he was making no progress
whatsoever on advancing checkmating the
black king and so I mean he has the
ability to do that now
I like it yeah it's a good a good
sacrifice and now he can go rook up to
eight to pin this thing Wow boy boys so
quick I mean he said that instantly
isn't that I don't know how he did that
so quickly I think he saw the plan from
the get-go and now he's in trouble
Ludwig's looking at us the last five
moves that four boys played it says 2.5
seconds 0.1 seconds 5.6 seconds 1.1
seconds 3.8 seconds is how much time you
spent in the last five moves it was very
deliberate III like he sacrificed the
Queen to capture two rooks and he
understood that this would not only lead
to losing his Queen but losing his
knight and then possibly losing a pawn
but he'd have a better attack and now he
doesn't better attack rather than just
sitting with this you know thought what
was waiting for something to happen and
maybe get the Queen free so I was sick
that was also a gambit does pay off hey
you know there's League of Legends guys
right look they're boring on the what do
you cut what's on the rift but they're
night like there's no rhyme here but
League of Legends is what I want man so
let me ask you something so you see that
black
has a queen and White has two rooks in a
night so the two works at night are
worth more but if you had this position
from the white side would you feel
confident in your potential to win this
game or do you still think that it's too
closed off for white to get anything
done just yet
I mean he's gonna have to push his king
right like he's gonna have to like make
some advanced with his pawns here and
it's such like the pawns haven't done
anything yet they're on the seventh rank
and so they have to move so far to get
anything done I don't know I mean
talking about black here close I feel
like you can't just get this done with
your queen by yourself I can so you need
to push all your pawns and you can get
this done as white with two rooks that's
actually an exceptional point because
you know this sounds obvious but two
ropes are two pieces so you can actually
apply pressure on a square whereas just
a lone Queen that's not enough so that
was a really astute point there so rook
to be one this Knight can come to e4 at
some point these rooks can come up the
board on the B file and just don't blend
or background check me there's a rook
here this night here you'll be okay but
at some point you should probably
consider pushing upon so as king of
squares to run to and he throws in the
94 checking box box his thirty seconds
left
yeah box box took so much time trying to
find the the Queen trap and never found
it unfortunately but now is working with
I mean seconds to the minutes that boy
bo has yeah poor boys up three and a
half minutes and has the two rooks the
night for the Queen it looks like he's
going to secure the full point but box
box is trying Queen f5 that Knight moves
maybe you lose this pawn on c2 and if
you lose that pawn then the pawn on d4
becomes a passed pawn and there are
ghosts I don't see all that oh he missed
it
the King is on a potentially vulnerable
diagonal so he had this from queen c6
before to check the king and there was a
96 that he would be able to take I see I
see I do like the pawn push it's yeah
you should push again there he goes with
it and I think that boy boys gonna take
the pawn yeah that makes sense I mean
the night it's not gonna help get a mate
and it's like it's a little I mean he's
mischievous and he can work around but I
think you're fine without it
ideally you'd be able to stop the pawn
to Knight to c3 made sense to try to get
your Knights at d1 but here we see D
rooks versus the Queen now very
different yeah yeah I know this kind of
sucks cuz then even if he uh pushes up
this pawn then they can just get like a
check for voyboy
which just takes too much time to react
to with 27 seconds it's gonna take more
than five he's gonna lose time and so we
can keep throwing on some checks right
and I think you will let's listen to
voyboy to see if he feels confident in
his chances to convert this position
he's completely quiet really focused
running mate in one
well he pushes and I trap the Queen in
the King and I will can't have me right
let's check me well he saw it oh my god
dude holy
oh he's Albert's of East it'll but much
differently before I was a tough game
what the hell did I was up at peace and
I freaking almost lost my queen holy
that's high praise from voyboy for his
opponent no talk of any actresses or
actors you know I think it's a good
point it's a good point he was up a
night right off rib and then uh box box
made it tight again okay well everybody
stay tuned because there will be a
second game box of us will have a chance
to even the score and we will be
bringing Hikaru Nakamura back so stay
right - I love books tired of me so stay
where you are we'll bring a car on we'll
be back in just a few minutes and he's
back he pretty much ran a marathon
sprinted to the wall
drove to the get new router but he's
back Hikaru thanks for coming back for
us it's good to be back I heard that
I've missed a lot of fun fun fun times
to put it mildly
we needed you because Ludwig and I were
on the verge of becoming friends and
that can't really happen so I also just
miss out on your commentary and analysis
like when they were talking specifically
about Gianni sins
I knew he car would have a great clip in
this spot and we miss out on it so I'm
glad you're here now because this lovely
I'm a very wholesome person I don't know
what you're talking about
lucky car we all know what happens
hikaru something funny happens he's a
little inappropriate does this it fade
see different scene where his face bust
out laughing because deep down this GM's
got a dirty sense of humor fairly true
good good assessment Ludwig that's not
it's not far from the truth but yeah
these guys played game 1 and and it was
500 all around I'm trying to keep up
with them but box box is a different
animal I don't know I don't like the
opening like the first like 10 moves or
something I saw a white queen down in
the corner but wasn't boy it was just up
at night I thought and then and then
somehow it became complicated I saw like
a queen against two works near the end
right before it ended so I was just
confused by what happened he was up at
night and then captured pawn on on on b7
and then had his queen get trapped and
they spent a long time just trying to
figure out what to do until the void boy
gambit came into play okay okay
so he got the Queen trapped down there
okay but it was winning yes it was so it
was good and then he went all the way
out here Queen h4 and this is a very
good move it was Ludwick suggestion so I
didn't suggest it all hands so whatever
I'm just I'm just new to chess it was a
good move he's trying to free the Queen
and then we saw a massive exchange here
and that was the big mistake out so you
had to take this pawn on d6 the more
advanced pawn he took this opponent b2
and then it was all void way from there
and he converted this well but it wasn't
at the end because because he could stop
to chuck me right right okay so yeah so
when was he end up losing this pawn and
then giving the knight back mm-hmm and
at this point here I he went ASIC was
still still playable but right so they
can't get escape okay that's how that's
how it occurred cuz cuz I heard that it
was winning I saw this winning that I
heard his winning then like I started
looking towards the end again as I was
getting back and yeah I did kind of one
went sideways but still good win
nonetheless for for boy boy and I guess
box box was pretty serious though that's
very stoic he was a little sullen after
we cut to him cuz this is his this is
his match this is like his David versus
Goliath moment he doesn't care about the
finals he cared about beating voyboy
right exactly yeah so I mean I don't
blame him I'd be pretty it's pretty
tough to lose a game like that but I
think the faculty was completely lost
and he actually had a chance later on as
is a good sign I mean he has white which
is what he wants right I mean you want
white in the second game after you lose
in a must-win game so I think I think
he's still very much in the game he is
and here's the white pieces he just
surprised
boy boy with the caro-kann but even
though he was someone is a first time
opening preparation worked just at the
end of his preparation he actually
blundered so if we go back to the
opening real quick he was surprised by
this Queen b5 check and he needed to put
his Knight to d7 to block the check and
protect the bishop instead he went
knight c6 because he was still thinking
about how the knight wants to go to c6
or more than square and that's where
preparation has to be not just about
memorizing a series of moves but
thinking about what your opponent just
right exactly yeah that's that's
unfortunate um but again he's got white
he just needs to refocus and I think he
can definitely do it
but it is hard because in a competitive
I guess like I don't know but I love a
would have a better better cake on this
and I think I would but because I think
across various games trying to react to
when you lose I'm not sure there's that
like a hard set like thing that you did
wrong to lose and other games like maybe
you did something wrong by the only as
clear-cut words here in like five
seconds you can go and see exactly what
you did wrong I think box box certainly
did that so I think when when you can
have that instant like knowledge it
makes it hard psychologically perhaps to
recover unlike say say in other games
right exactly yeah so I would say in
chess specifically they show you your
blunder right after and so yeah they
don't do that other games they just like
when you when you get peaked and Valerie
and then lose your gunfight you usually
just call him an idiot and move on with
your day right but right calm doesn't
say hey man that was a bad but you know
enough about valor and uh I'll coach you
on that later Hikaru we're in it and
he's he's ditched the karo no he's he
did [__] oh he's white yeah he's white
what what is he playing actually why is
it playing this modern did you help him
Robert I didn't know I
so I told voyboy when I work with him
that I would not help him with anything
with from respect to box box I worked at
box box too and so I was gonna prepare
them for each other when I did my lesson
with Boyd way it was all just tactics
and thinking about the position
psychology stuff but boy wait Cheney box
that's got exactly what he wanted with
this item I don't like this opening I
just don't like it I don't like it bye
boy boy because he walked into Albert's
kind of wheelhouse here well I feel like
it's very easy Albert should know to
castle the king and then push the pawn
to f4 of course he needs to push the
other pawn to d3 as well but it's it's
very straightforward it's a plan that
he's looked at in all that all of these
different setups so that's why I really
don't like this choice by boy boy I
don't like it at all
what about you love it when you see this
opening no I just know I'm only worried
about Albert Albert likes doing stuff
that he's comfortable with and I think
he was kind of uncomfortable with the
caro-kann and obviously just made like a
simple mistake in the opening but this
is the one like he knows he just likes
doing this when we play blindfolded he
goes for this cuz he just knows that
it's like the safest way to go and he'll
probably get it off regardless of what
black does yeah he wants 4 h 3 d 3 pauna
4 he here's the exact setup and actually
he's very fortunate that on the move one
void would correspond d 6 because the
lines that albert struggles most with
isn't this bishops on c5 this bishops
here I think he'll be okay let's just an
envoy boy dear how he's dealing with
this position here takes takes takes
aches
okay bishop
I figure each six it's not bad is it bad
not that it's bad boy boy sweet feels
like a weekend my castle a little bit
but it does permit his bishop from
developing to a great square and
painting my night so I think it's okay
I want to attack the center so yeah III
like I like what he's doing
again I worry though for voice at the
center white white gets us these pawns
in the center that take a lot of space
and the idea is for black here I think
are very very difficult to find like for
example I don't know if you felt the
same way Robert but one thing that I try
to tell people who has coaches that they
need to have pawns in the center of the
board because the idea is if you don't
have pawns taking central squares you
have to understand where you push the
pawns when you try to break break the
pawn structure of your opponent and in
this sort of a position it's very hard
for black to come up with ideas and I've
always hated these positions even even
my own games against grandmasters cuz
the white plans are so easy I'm
completely with you I think that white
is already attacking something and you
see that here blacks like ok that was a
very important decision but now Albert
can take with pretty much any of his
pieces of this pawn or with the knight
or with the bishop and all are going to
be good moves and black actually just
it's just a Ludwig understands we're
referring to here so let's say you take
them and Bishop yeah this is what I said
I said pawn break that's something I
think most people in chat as well are
gonna be like what are you talking about
it makes no sense chatter jet so white
has all these pawns at centers so like
for example when you try to break like
the pawn structure the way you would do
this for example say push the pawn to d5
Seyi five yep night night at d7 pawn to
d4 to protect the pawn and now pawn to
c5 want to see five so it's like what it
is is like you try to attack the pawns
with your own paws but when you don't
have paws of the center of the board and
you have less space
you basically have to play for this
theme so you don't just end up getting
pushed back further and further where
you've no space for your pieces and
these sorts of themes like understanding
where you try to attack the pawns is
something that's very advanced it's
something that someone who's probably
below master level is gonna struggle
with greatly so that's why I when I was
coaching especially I really made sure
not to suggest these sorts of openings
and why it really worries me for voyboy
here because the ideas of knowing where
he's gonna have to push his pawns in the
right order to sort of neutralize all of
all of White's ideas and so I that's why
I really don't like this I'm gonna pull
a different Robert card take the road
less traveled I do like it I think
voyboy does something that most of us in
this tournament don't cuz we're we're
trying to think constantly of the
openings were taught in what's correct
in I think at the higher level you guys
take abstract ideas attack the center
attack the right side move our forces
over invoice doing that so he
understands what he has to do he has his
reso netra and I don't know if box box
does he just knows that this is a pretty
good position that like he like he could
be pretty good position and he's doing
that but I think if you don't know
exactly what you're supposed to be
attacking or better yet what they're
gonna be attacking are attacking it can
be really just tricky I don't know I
find I find it person like really tricky
when I don't know what I'm attacking but
I know I'm supposed to doing this and so
having to remember that or just being
able to figure out how you're gonna
implement what the idea of your opening
is I think it's hard and I think boy boy
knows how to do that better than I think
anyone in the tournament yeah make sense
yeah I would think that boy boy and
Hutch are the two players who are best
at that yeah that's because they have
more long-term experience so even if
they don't get exactly what they
prepared for they're able to understand
the distinction
whereas we just Albert box box he put
his piece on the wrong square in
response to check
the bounce right lovely mm-hmm the
bounce you saw that bar go up yeah
that's that it do be bouncing it's
bouncing and part of the reason why is
oh my gosh it's it doesn't know what it
wants here but White has a huge Center
so if you play d4 to hit Cara's point
like White has the very easy control of
the center and then black has to decide
at which moment and what palm plan am I
going for with a c5 and he plays c5
right away which is not a bad move
pretty good move because also oh my gosh
yeah oh gone for Oh let's listen to box
box to hear if he's confident his
position because he really should be
sorry about the notifications my funds
loud and he's quiet
any can you silence my phone for me
hey what do you think at the androids
not the man I love taking 1 megapixel
photos nuttin yeah we're gonna have an
argument he's locked in here I'm glad I
didn't push the spawn up too early I
remember being told like if you don't
need to push the pond don't push it
wait for the option or hang on to the
options and now we got this video Tom
that Robert yeah mm-hmm
very nice I'm pretty sure I get it
briefly just bring it up sometimes this
is close to winning for white actually
when I look at it I think he might get
worried about taking this pawn on b7
with his bishop because he's worried
about his king that's what I think it
might hold him back
I've always loved his music though oh
nice he's got this he's got this under
control we're gonna see a third tie
break today it's when I turn to wonder
I'd be hype okay yeah it has to give me
a stroke or he gives me his night okay
hang on so write a go for it Gary go for
it and gets an insane diagonal it's a
big decision trust yourself you have
nothing to lose and true he needs to win
I think I'll find it cuz the alternative
move isn't I should still take it but to
be very careful let's plug up the deck
when you push pawn to d4 here but very
tough to play yeah Oh actually 94 is a
good move to 94 pawn takes pawn up five
but that's too advanced yeah I was about
to say that that's a that's really hard
to find because 94 you're giving up this
pawn on e5 and if you take putting f5
just to keep this Bishop stuck on g7
that's a that's at least five head
probably ten it yeah yeah they're very
hard to see that idea if you're not at
least an international master yeah it's
just it's not very common to see that so
a lot of the idea we're talking about
and yeah when you take on e5 I like is
trying to open up all these squares for
the pieces square like the e5 square
like if I could you take you five I'm
sorry could I could something like if I
show you on the board if takes Knight
takes and in comes this nights like f3
and blacks pieces are coming flying fly
yeah yeah yeah because then because when
they're flying it's harder to catch him
I got very dangerous for white but he
has to go Queen d2 I think here get the
Queen out of this pin and then he can
recapture this pawn with the knight and
that [__] bond on this edge of the
bishop on the edge of the board is
really not very well placed right and I
wonder if he's going to refrain because
I think it is tempting to take as that
also opens up your bishop towards the
black King but it brings this knight in
so quickly then I think he I think he's
scared he's mentioned he's scared about
his king but I'm sure what voyboy thinks
let's bring him on hear his thoughts and
they see if he believes he has a real
attacking Knight takes actually lead
some Warren lines of play for me that
could work out oh he could go like he
could move his knight and then I don't
know a noise can I still pin no that's
actually really powerful so yeah I know
actually seems pretty good
okay he went clean up instead so if I
take
obviously talking this square nice a
nice not pin anymore I didn't just take
back here goes for it and you can see
him he sees I was scanning across the
board left and right mm-hmm
he's really trying to find his
conversation the cool thing is that box
box put him in such a tough spot that x
equal right any cakes with a knight very
important move here very very knight
takes
you're gonna see this I mean [__] 5/3
is the best move here but it's a very
hard move to play I think although by
process of elimination if you think that
your bishop when a tribes in trouble
you heard listen Christmas is like night
here threatening also night here if he
picks here and I take here King has to
go back to this square off the night
check and I could go I go here check
these fairs are covered King goes here
then what's my follow-up he's gonna
great trip here in fact takes what is it
enough so he's thought through a lot and
he ends up in a check obviously at that
point it's not like wow wow wow figured
it out oh he just grifter ripped it
that's crazy he talked about that night
move for like an hour
well I was Hikaru suggested Bishop f3
and by process of elimination that's how
he did he thought about 95 going for the
attack but then he realized that this
kind of attack on the long diagonal is
very valuable and he we heard him
working through all these different
possibilities
he realized that bringing the 19 who was
probably bad because the knight was
captured the bish when I tried so he
then moved the bishop away from the
square honestly just impressive
calculation there we heard him going
through it step by step
yeah this is fantastic play by boy [__]
about three and now you can retreat the
bishop on the diagonal objectively I
think black is probably winning here but
boy glass still has to find some moves
and of course box box has to bring the
other rook in you have to go rook e1
here the one work that's not in the game
the one piece that's not on a good
square and he really has to play that
move Toronto or else bad things are
gonna happen it's just hard mad because
you
it's a lame move you feel like you had
him on the ropes you feel like you're
about to get something big happening he
plays f3 all of a sudden you can't do
any of that Bishop and so you want to
apply some pressure and right so this is
also a good move try to double try to
stack the rooks right now if whoever
finds Bishop b7 he deserves a prize but
he doesn't see it okay okay play g5
which is not a terrible move right but
it does look scary because that night
did want to come to g5 he was actually
correct that his Knight 1 and jump
forward because from g5 you're hitting
this h3 pawn and potentially going to
the f3 square so that's the rub down can
you maybe show this line so for example
say Bishop e7 instead this is the track
exist and now like on work up just play
a random move a 3 sorry just play a 3
here the black can play Knight g5 rook
f1 and then white black and put the
other night on e5 with the idea of just
I don't even know how to how to put up
with the knight is going to f3 and with
two of them aiming about square just
crushing for black whereas in the game
after putting the pawn on g5 you lose
two access for one of the Knights to
jump in to that critical square because
now I can move the knight and there's no
square for the knight anymore
that's no it's good to illustrate that
because the F 3 square is important for
the the knight jump and this Menem h7
that's probably going to be a
problematic piece for maybe the rest of
the game but I'm also noticing that box
box is down to two and a half minutes to
void boys 3:40 so that's a pretty big
lead on the clock for more boy despite
the material deficit right agreed agreed
is passed like four three or four moves
have been a minute which is which is a
long time to think I don't know I feel
like yeah I feel like it's hard to
switch the mind set to just
get the rook in and just get like a more
favorable position I feel like he had
something going and and he lost it and I
don't think it's clicked yet but I think
it's easier so just move your night away
I like that that's great that was good
right guys yeah yeah well there's one
big brother you might see it something
very deep here or it's you know it's not
gonna happen soup lays out five but wait
Allegra are you familiar with this
concept of night on f5 night on f5 yeah
absolutely not okay so there's a saying
in chess if you can get tonight let's
say you're white you got a knight to
five square if you're black you get a
Knights a four square it's worth it's
like the most important square you can
ever get a night to so something like
this you see how this Knight gets this
square uh-huh if you get a knight to the
square where it can't be removed usually
it's one of those strongest attacking
pieces you'll ever have in any game just
so-so box box was very close to getting
that but boy boy stopped it here by
pushing the pawn and preventing it so
this is a excellent move by by by boy
boy and a great response by box box and
actually let's tune in to here box boxes
thoughts it's getting to be a critical
time for him under two minutes in the
clock
and we're not really listening to
anything because it's pretty terrifying
I think I finally have a good mood now I
oh here this force this is Bishop out
you can tell how nervous he is his hands
shaking
that was crazy terrible movie night g3
93 box box come on 93 don't don't hurt
anyone
don't blunder check me two one no III
come on box box double attack come on 93
you can do it can't take
can't take
the good news is his move is also pretty
good to initiate an attack but Knight g3
was extremely powerful he could still do
it right next depending on the next move
yeah but he sees it now he just
highlighted I should've done this one
first and I just said it but that that
shows improvement because he recognizes
like just in the heat of the moment
Breck has oh shoot 20 seconds ago I
shouldn't make that move instead yeah
okay so you should take the bishop and
now move the knight to d4 move your
knight to d4 it's also not a bad move
and boy boy has to see his 97th under
attack by the Queen kids no it's got to
go Knight c3 here don't please
hovering
oh boy no I'm fine I'm saying he's five
but to 2gm chastiser tonight there's 94
with the fork of the Queen in the road I
think I'm fine
oh my god I'm barely fine can you get
out with check there's Rick I stop and I
have to check oh we need four or
something maybe I don't know anyway
let's just watch it
oh wait
oh no this isn't that great just realize
it how big is the time to worry about it
though
I agree easily quickly before come on
Queenie for
don't sac the Queen
oh no time I think he's done maybe three
moves under five seconds his whole game
and he's gonna have all them Oh
the clock did him in yeah he's no
and Boyd Boyd plays a lot of blitz so
yeah
yeah so he was you know he I'm gonna try
something he's trying to go for one last
little cozy hoping it takes with Queen
they could put him in check well he did
he's gonna take with the Queen because
that covers the squares that you can
check I see I don't think I did it
either just on the off-chance how you
doesn't notice I also didn't see that
the Queen covered it yeah boy boy
definitely sees that I'll tell you what
though in our nine hundred matches that
move crushes they never see a common and
then you get a free Queen it's true it
was still it was the right choice it was
a hundred percent the right choice to do
that at the end of the game 100 percent
he was already lost in a game so
definitely the right the right decision
to hope that voyboy wouldn't see it I
totally agree with that choice though
it's very good and we're talking about
this choice here at the end is after
Queen 67 which was good because what was
threatening to go 96 with a deadly fort
that the Queen covers both checking
score so you might as well go for your
down and queen for his rook and if he
doesn't see it you gotta take the Queen
but gotta get props to box box he put up
a really good fight he actually had this
game and well before we take a quick
break to get the players on for an
interview I just wanna remind everybody
what tomorrow is
because hey Ludwig you're not gonna be
talking to us anymore will ya nope I
have to do a bit of playing myself and
Hikaru you're the one who said xqc is a
surefire lock to move on is that right
let's just kill something light what is
xqc doing right now is he playing chess
in preparation for his match oh no it
looks like he's still playing ten hours
into the last of us part two do you guys
ever do that before tournaments you GM's
ever just boot up Last of Us part two
and then play that for ten hours before
your big game
no no interesting interesting that's
interesting
we'll see what happens I guess well he's
to five head for us so he has a unique
path and let him do victory yesterday
and lovely you know you have your work
cut out for you tomorrow but we have to
get ready for his interview bring Eon
boy boy and box box stay where you are
we'll bring the players on and just come
in we are back we have both boy boy and
bottom joining us congrats war boy how
you feeling right now is pretty tough
match yet thank you yeah
really hard honestly like it was so so
easily winnable for for both sides I'm
still a little bit shaky but yeah I you
know Albert one of my best friends it
was it was a little tragic that we had
to meet and one knock one of it the
other out but you know I'm I'm glad we
had a good match and you know I barely
able to come through and Albert how are
you feeling I know of course the
resultant go your way but you played
some very entertaining dress today I
feel great I had a great time I uh I
mostly just didn't want to go down like
slowly and uncomfortably bleed out so
you want to go valiantly and play a
fighting game yeah I never expected to
win but I'm really happy that up until
like the last couple moves or I ran out
of time and blundered it was like still
very up in the air as to who would win
and green taking us back to the first
game because you we heard you we tuned
in and we heard you talking about the
preparation you did in the Carl Cohn and
you're like oh finally I get some my
preparation and then it seemed like boy
boy tricked you or you felt
uncomfortable after he checked you with
his Queen yeah I saw it on the replay
afterwards that like I easily could have
not lost my bishop - like Saul's like ah
he got me uh that's totally my bed
that's just me not paying enough
attention in class
wait Howard what wait I don't even know
how are you supposed to save the bishop
I other night other night moved to block
the check yeah then it protects then it
protects the bishop yeah but you still
played a great game you went out
valiantly I will say it was like Captain
Dan always dreamed of from Forrest Gump
you were winning the whole way I look I
didn't know what the hell is going on
I'll be honest but I was looking at the
bouncy thing and it was it was white the
whole way through men up until literally
one move and I would not listen to the
vodkas he car was very very upset about
it he was writhing the whole time it was
uh it was when you did it
who was it was yeah I gave one the
knight fork yeah well yeah I mean it's
it's one you had and I think you saw
this in the in the game actually the
second game when you played Bishop to d4
I think after you made the move you
realize you should have put the knight
on
three yeah if you had done that one move
I think he almost certainly would have
won the game because the whole attack
for black falls apart immediately and I
was just wondering like if it was really
tough in those moments when you saw some
of these moves after you made made these
decisions uh it definitely feels bad too
like it happened like three times during
that series where I like I make him two
seconds late I'm like all there was a
much better move available but that's
definitely just like because boy put me
in a lot of tricky situations I had to
spend a lot of time on like it's just
like because he played well I was forced
to spend a lot of time on those moves
and I didn't have that time to think
about the more critical moves like that
right and boy boy you're just saying how
it's bittersweet because you're you had
a win at matching it's your friend do
you think it impacted you at all during
the match itself are you were able to
forget about it because in chess at the
top level all the players know each
other quite well and oftentimes you to
forget your friends in the heat of the
moment just to play the game in front
you know so after I won the first game
someone posted a clip or Albert was like
boy boy is actually a really good guy
like one of my one of my close friends
and I first I was like wait he's trying
to get in my head so I get distracted by
our friendship and then I run it down
but no actually when we were playing it
was just you know trying to play a
really strong chess player and you know
I knew obviously it was Albert on the
other side but it was just it was just
it was just bored in pieces at that
point to be honest what about you Albert
what about me what oh they didn't have
anything to do with this game well you
wanted to play board work from the very
beginning that's the only reason you
entered this company yeah master promo I
spent the last month and a half
practicing out my I set I can make it a
good match was it worth it
financially in terms of like
satisfaction yeah I had a great time
I had a great time learning the last few
weeks you get same bright I haven't
stream League in like two weeks but it
was it's been really fun to like spam
chess and try to improve like to be
honest if I didn't
hardcore play like the last like week
two weeks and actually try to improve
like Albert would have like wiped the
floor with me like I think it's kind of
its kind of it almost like inspirational
how much every player in this tournament
has improved to just get to level we can
compete at each other and have such
close games and like you know have
underdogs taking games and like in like
that like those that match good one
either way for example like I don't know
it's really cool and I feel like that's
to any like young little Timmy's out
there trying to you know get better
anything or get better at chess for
example like do we're all are all the
streamers are just like poppy goes right
and we were able to actually learn a lot
and improve and you know it did help
that we have some some GM coaches and
stuff holding our hands along the way
also big house all my coaches I don't
want to get cut off at the end so yeah
hey Robert I see you bro thank you
hikaru I see you Daniel near a disc II
my man Hans what's up dude
I am sir abilities era thank you guys
for all the help and you know just
lessons and all that stuff over the last
few weeks I think I speak on behalf of
like all the competitors that like we
really appreciate it and I think the
community also really appreciates
because you know so many free lessons
being redistributed through that forum
to the to the to the chest to the Chess
fans so I feel like it's been a really
really cool time I don't mean to cut you
off boy boy sorry I thought I was going
on no you definitely do not speak on
behalf of slicker voxbox I gotta I gotta
ask you how many how many coaches have
you had through this all the same ones
he did interesting wait a second egg you
had Gotham right your boy I had a couple
extra one I went around asking a lot of
people no one's saying about the secret
gambling ring that the GM's are having
behind our backs all right for teaching
us bad nobody taught Albert that way
move
way so are you like Stannis Albert where
you try to collect all the GM coaches so
you could defeat me is that what
happened where you missing one in the
end or what happened yeah magneto
wouldn't respond oh my god dude dad
you're so close I got lucky man well boy
boy you're moving on to the finals
you're going to face hutch how do you
anticipate that mashup going yeah so I
was showering while hutch was playing
him but I did see that NIM took the
first game off him and it came down to
the Blitz tie breaker
I think hutch is really really strong I
think going into this like everyone was
hyping up huh like hutch has been
playing for like 20 years he invented
chess he's Magnus Carlson's like alter
form stuff like that like I I mean
people my chat has been trying to scare
me like very convincingly so I think
hutch is really good it'll be a great a
great finals match and I'm excited to
you know battle him for the the chest
pogchamp crown i guess and well box boss
what about you so your tournament here
is done fortunate supply chest cuz it
seems like you really love the game and
we've talked about many times it's so
clear how much progress you've made
you have really improved perhaps more
than anybody since pogchamp begin so
what's your chest future looking like ah
yeah i
during this like last month i i man to
find my old tournament records from
elementary school I found out I was a
700 ello Andy doesn't happen the
progress as long as there's something to
compete over I I am always down to keep
playing me and third grade you would
have great games oh yeah as long as
there's like something whether it's
which rivals are like some sort of
rivalry or I don't have to face a GM I'm
always down to keep trying to improve
and kick boy boys ass next time same
dude I'm looking forward to it yeah I
hope they keep doing more like pogchamp
stress events it's been it's been really
fun
it's certainly as well for you it's not
over boy boy you have to play hutch
tomorrow so best of luck to you thank
you
you like hutch you're gonna need it and
well box works happy belated birth I
wish your birthday I wish you happy
birthday on the day but happy belated
Happy Birthday over wait so wait wait
yeah where we gonna say something I
didn't cut you off no I had nothing oh
so wait why did I why did I have to play
my other good friend Moe in the
quarterfinals and he was his birthday
and yesterday was Albert's birthday and
then I had to play Albert is it hutches
birthday like tomorrow like what's going
on here there's like it is Hodges
birthday treants 47 tomorrow it'll be
brutal man you got to give one birthday
guy wait do we need this way should we
sing however happy birthday though
because we birth day yeah but it's boule
was yesterday wait wait come you see
birthday man's in shed there you know
when you see my son um oh happy birthday
I'm pretty sure I led the charge yes you
that was very courageous
wait Albert left that's what he was
afraid of you singing happy birthday
[Laughter]
happy birthday buddy he didn't want that
let me ask you we have a very important
match coming up tomorrow and it's not
your finals match against hutch it is
xqc against Ludwick who do you see as
the favorite no and wait before you
finish we start ludwig did say he hates
league of legends so now okay I didn't
say I hate legal legends actually love
legal legends I don't know how to really
what's your favorite champion name every
skill name every item in the game I
don't get that far man it puts me to
sleep earlier ah so you love League of
Legends but you don't have a favorite
champion I see I like I like League of
Legends to fall asleep to alright I
can't fall asleep with with the you know
with nyquil every day hey that makes a
lot of sense cuz you know I've been
putting on your stream lately and puts
me right out in like half a second flat
to be honest so you watch my stream
I have tuned it you're a guy man that's
obviously respected but um I'd be happy
to show you the league row Sunday but I
think honestly
i'ma go with you know the young xqc no
offense Ludwig though hey me bro
I saw him I asked saw xqc kind of Smurf
today and XE she actually plays league
so until until you you know you're not a
fake League family like Fiddlesticks
season three would rave everybody in the
jungle with no remorse
alright wait you actually played 33 yeah
I almost made it to level 30 and then I
backed out okay respect hopefully no one
in chat just spam Fiddlesticks and you
just like picked up on that but I
believe you okay now I'm gonna to say I
don't know who's gonna win honestly it's
it could go either way I could go either
way
like straight-up give me here GM's your
GM black book I need to go through coach
by like one GM everyone else blows me
off
Robert Hess makes fun of me for my
English major talks about his wait wait
wait wait wait last night I was eat your
freakin stream la 4:30 in the morning my
time saying I was happy to help you out
so don't you try to turn this on me
Robert that's just something that
happened that I'm lying about for
content please don't bring it up right
now Jesus you know the class Robert wait
Louie if so box wants to cry tried to
collect all the coaches if you collect
all the chest books I saw you with that
what was it like the end game divorce
keys
yeah a divorce keys yeah just get like
purgatory it's you know 10/10 schemes
ease like if you collect it like the top
five I feel like you'll just like
integrate into your brain and you'll
just become a GM overnight I'll just use
them as booster seats so I can see much
more clearly smart boy I got nothing
else for you but congrats again man oh
I'm sure I'll stop by in your stream
later so celebrate but not too much
because you have a really tough
challenge ahead of you tomorrow
so always the finals tomorrow mm-hmm
1:00 p.m. tomorrow nope 1:00 p.m.
thanks Louie go boss hey I think me and
Albert might be doing after this also
guessing them friendly a friendly banter
going but yeah I think I think thank you
for the good luck I'll do my best
against such guys thank you very much
for the interview and the games
shouts all the fans watching love you
guys love the chests community thanks
for being so cool and you know embracing
and awesome and yeah thanks guys see boy
a spike and we have the champ chip
bracket set it will be void boy against
hutch I think that most people before
the event started you said these would
be the finalists nobody would be
surprised and then the consolation
bracket we still have Ludwig versus xqc
tomorrow at noon pacific time and then
we will see the winner of that take on
moist critical he beat slicker in the
other semifinals so Ludwig it's been a
pleasure man
I'm kind of sad that you won't be
commenting Marcus you'd be busy play you
know what I'll do both I'll just solo
commentate while I'm playing I think
honestly honestly I feel like we should
probably just give me the championship
prize money and just throw me as a
commentator for it you know what I mean
cause like my commentary skills I feel
like at this point it's so hard for me
to transition that I'm the only one out
here doing both you know what I mean
taking Alex's job and beating players
true true but we'll see I do want some
coaching I might hit you up Robert I'd
hit you up he car but I think you'll
probably just teach me something wrong
so xqc can win one I mean I was probably
help your opponent I'm something it's
probably gonna be playing a lot the last
of us for yeah I think hit our 11 of the
last of us two and his title is further
in the game than them and it's pointing
these ways so if I if he took a chess
break then the title would be a lie and
we know that he doesn't want to do that
so you know maybe 30 hours into his
stream you'll help him out if not though
hey I'm here I'm here man if you want to
help me just you know for sure
yeah I might take you up on it but at
any rate I mean certainly good luck and
it's been it's been a lot of fun having
you both as a both both playing but also
you're the contraries but I've really
enjoyed it Wow well after that
sentimental moment I think we have to
sign off thank you to everybody who's
been tuning in thank you to HS calm the
production staff everybody who's been
helping out the mods it's been great and
tomorrow will be the last day so don't
be sad be glad that it happened peace
out everybody till tomorrow
you
[Music]